Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab, the podcast,
and today on the podcast,
sorta kind of following in the footsteps of our inheritance show [inaudible] we
have, uh, it's a feel good story that,
that you may not know how to feel about. It's like a bad feel.
Good story. It's, I don't know. Okay.
I'm willing to be confused in my feelings if that's what it's going to take.
Yes. Let me in. Let me get things rolling and introduce a reporter,
Andrea Seabrook. Hello. Hey. How's it going?
She'll be telling us this next story. Good. How are you?
I'm excited to hear what, what it is you've discovered on your adventures.
I have discovered many things. Young grasshopper. I'm ready. Okay.
So,
so I went to this place, I'll entry road into Patuxent,
which I sort of knew existed,
but I thought it was just like a little place north of Washington u s department
of Interior US Geological Survey, but Texas Wildlife Research Center.
There's a guard house and you drive into this place and it's like driving
seriously. It's like driving out of the beltway and into Jurassic
[inaudible],
tall old growth trees.
Suddenly sort of wash and meadows and verdant,
a hidden magical forest.
It really gives you a sense of what this place must have been like before we
came in and sort of asphalted everything
you just to set things up bit. Okay.
Scientists in this place are basically trying to go backwards.
They're trying to essentially re evolve a species of bird that has lost its
history. Which bird is that? Whooping cranes. Whooping Crane? Yes.
Whooping cranes. Oh yeah. I know about that.
This place has been minimized a lot. There have been movies made about it.
It's sort of the famous example of conservation, but
when Andrea went to check it out,
she discovered this mystery or this question that I'd never,
I never knew about.
It's right at the center of what the scientists are doing, so, so I'm,
so I met this guy. Hello Andrea? Yes. Hi.
Named John French to come on in. He's got kind of a Walrus,
like mustache and Straw hat.
I don't know if that tells you anything else about it, but just paint a picture.
We need to get you a little a badge here.
This guy has been working with these cranes for like three decades while we're
here at the whooping crane observatory and the first thing he does is take me to
a duck blind. What's a duck blind?
It's like a tiny little house up on stilts. It's,
it's raised off the ground that we're walking up steps, steep steps,
almost like a ladder and you can,
you get inside this tiny little place with shutters that they can carefully and
quietly open and then look down on the grouping crane.
These birds. Oh mine.
That's crazy. It's crazy. Regular quarter of the
female females sitting on a Nashville,
unbelievably beautiful in tall.
These are huge. Three,
four feet tall with Luffy Downey white bodies perched on top of these two ball
legs. Buddy stretcher when he's here for us,
they're willing. Spread is about Pete,
sometimes nine feet and then the from the, from the front of the body,
the this be almost swan,
like neck curves and rise.
Is that to a head that it's white all the way up.
Then it's got this right.
Please read across the top of the head the red cap that's actually bare skin.
That skin where they come into breeding condition,
that thing swells up and fills with blood gets brighter. I have
never in my life seen anything like this and here's why.
By the 1930s humans had destroyed enough of their territory and in fact just
like shot and eaten enough cranes that there were,
they believe 16 left in the wild.
One six one six. Wow.
And you know how many breeding females were in that population for?
So they were right on the brake.
They were right on the brink of the brain at that point.
Most biologists sort of say it's extinct. Well,
if you're that close to the end,
then how do you bring an animal back from something like that?
Here's what they do.
Usually like two eggs on one building.
They have two cranes to just lay a bunch of eggs. We can get, you know, three,
four or five, sometimes even six or seven eggs from a single pair.
And the scientists gather those eggs walking up the hatchery now and they put
them in these giant incubators and see them,
the trays of eggs and they tilt back and forth to allow their patrol rotate when
they are about to hatch.
And they can tell because they start hearing these little like, you know,
this sounds like not that
parents take it across the ramen at your painter walk in there and next they
take these eggs,
put them in a room and these eggs hatch and the baby comes out and it thinks
who's my mother?
And then one of the one walls of this room is plexiglass and on the other side
of the wall isn't that doll whooping crane? Like a mother whooping crane? Yeah.
Call this an imprint model.
Baby can see a mother on the other side of the plexiglass and in fact the
whooping crane and the other side of the plexiglass will make these sounds.
These sort of sounds that say,
come here baby,
you know, cute baby. And so the baby,
here's the sound and, and runs towards that sound. And you know,
onc runs into the plexiglass because of course that is there.
Oh see they're not letting the baby get to the mom. Nope. Why not?
Because they don't have enough captive cranes to raise the number of eggs that
they produce.
And if a baby crane were to imprint on a mother crane that,
that we're going to stay, then it wouldn't migrate. Ah,
they don't want the baby chick to inherit the traits that that mom has now that
it's been raised by humans,
but they still somehow need the baby to see what a mom looks like. Yes.
I want to make sure that those young chicks know what they're supposed to be
when they grow up. So that,
so the check, here's that sand too.
It looks around it's pen and in the corner is that a fake whooping crane that
the scientist to put there?
We use a stuffed, um,
[inaudible] from a new swans,
but they put a whooping crane head on the top. That's kind of grim.
It's totally weird.
And the way they've taxidermied these hooping grains is to have the wings kind
of, yeah,
he's out a little bit so the checks can snuggle up under there and kind of kept
[inaudible]. Yeah, we have a heat lamp that is directed down, so it's warm,
right?
So the chicken snuggles up next to his fake mom and the very next thing that
happens is the humans walk into this room.
I'm Sharon Perrigo and I'm a technician here wearing these big giant crane
suits, big white costume, and it made it have a sheet,
just white fabric.
We tried to use that to conceal the human form. And here's, here's a key part.
They hold a cream puppet hand in one of their hands.
We use a puppet to point at things like the adults would point out food on the
ground or guide them and walk with them. I mean,
they have to be taught everything,
how to eat, how to swallow water. They have to be taught how to drink.
She showed me how she takes the puppet head and dips it into water and then
[inaudible]
tips the head back. The parents teach them how to do that.
So we have to use the puppets instead.
And in these giant bird suits and with the puppet heads,
they lead each little chick outside for the first time.
They're very curious and they get very excited about going on walks and seeing
butterflies and looking at bugs and see a pond for the first time and you know,
look at the frogs and try to catch the fish. And that's the fun part.
To see them act like cranes,
then they have to teach them something else that's really important but
completely unnatural in the wild who'd been great in pair lays usually two eggs,
one or both will hatch and if to one of the babies will be stronger than the
other and the mother will start to ignore the weaker one and that one will die.
One of those chicks dies.
The family has never more than three in the wild really. But these scientists,
they raise a whole flock of them at once
and often the first time we walk two chicks together, they fight.
There's a little bit of aggression packing run and, oh, because I guess
baby,
you've evolved instincts to mistrust the other babies at least in the beginning
of your life.
And so the trainers have to teach these baby chicks to tolerate each other.
We then gather them together in a, in a rather large group.
Then the scientists take them and put them on a track track. Exactly.
Almost like a running track.
And they teach the baby checks to go around and around and around the track
chasing a little propeller plane. They chase a plane.
It's like a hang glider with a big fan on the back.
Okay. And then they get imprinted on the aircraft and the costume andler that's
driving the aircraft. So they kind of think of this is mom or dad. Right.
And so when they learn to fly though, they fly behind the ultralight aircraft.
That's
very exciting. We'll just, that's very, oh, you get all choked up.
You know, it's just, it's we're doing,
we've done what we're supposed to do and they're doing what they're supposed to
do and it's very rewarding and you get all choked up about it and they're just
beautiful birds. They really are.
So they practice flying during the summer up in Wisconsin.
It gets strong [inaudible] they're good.
They're taking longer and longer flights.
And then when time for migration comes in late September or early October,
the ultra light takes off
heads down towards Florida in the birds follow them.
So we fly them down there to a couple of refugees in western Florida on the Gulf
coast and then we release them there.
And once the cranes have taken that journey once,
they never have to be shown it again.
So they like get it and they form breeding pairs. Wow.
Down in the wild. It just to break in thinking about how crazy this is,
these birds were hatched in an incubator,
cuddled by stuff's ones raised by humans and bird costumes then taught to eat
and drink by puppets.
Now they're flying behind an ultralight plane on a migration route that never
existed in nature. And it seems to be working.
Can, there used to be 16 birds now? About
500 give or take depending on when we're counting. Yeah,
all that kind of stuff. Wow. It's a huge accomplishment.
It's a huge accomplishment for this program,
for ecological biology and for humanity that we could even figure out how to do
something like this. You know,
there've been all these documentaries that show this undies,
unbelievable inspiring pictures of this light plane followed by these baby
cranes and it's so beautiful and it's like, oh, you know, humans are,
are doing what they should to their people who care
so much that we're finally putting all of this into, you know,
getting these cranes back and we're going to recover something.
But here's what, here's what happens next.
French says that in most cases the breeding pairs that are formed in the wild
will lay eggs.
They will sit on the eggs and do all the things that wild cranes are supposed to
do and then one day they,
they get up and walk away
without the baby, without the egg ever happen.
These birds seem to abandon their eggs before and patching.
For some reason it's puzzling. They just leave.
They just teach us walk away. They just get up and walk away. Yeah,
right, right. That's why.
Well, well we have a couple theories.
What we see in French says there are three big reasons it might be.
One is that uh, these birds are bothered by black flies.
Flies, black flies. Yeah. Black flies, black flies. These are not halfs fly.
They're not house flies. They're biting flies.
They burrow down under the feathers and bite and take a little blood meal.
These flies are infesting. The places where they nest,
we have pictures of just the head of a crane just completely covered with black
floods.
We have done some experimentation though to try and figure out if that is a
cause. And the data looks pretty good. Like, yeah. When,
when you're knocked down the black fly populations,
the nesting success seemed to go up a little bit,
but last year the data were quite a bit less clear cut, so,
so they're not sure if it's the flies. Exactly. That's one idea.
The second idea is that maybe they aren't getting enough to eat.
Do they have enough food and the right kinds of food to get them through the
incubation period? There's some kind of suggestive evidence that uh,
that might be a problem for them.
So they might be leaving their nest because they're just starving.
Maybe because we've changed the landscape so much,
but John French thinks the third possibility is really the most likely one,
which is what the rather odd, uh,
upbringing that these birds have in captivity.
He thinks they have so much baggage from such a screwy childhood.
They're, they're raised by animal caretakers in these funky costumes.
They're in a very small pen that has a stuffed swan. This is not normal.
A normal childhood for a crane.
And so he thinks that something that they're doing or not doing exactly.
Exactly. In that upbringing,
do you suspect might be thing that is causing problems later when they're trying
to be, yeah. The real answer is I have no idea.
So you don't even know what you're, what, you're not teaching the chair.
Absolutely. Right. Right.
This is perhaps the most difficult problem.
There are so many variables.
It could be that the birds aren't being kept warm enough or they're being kept
too warm.
Maybe they didn't have a role model for how long they get parented and so they
just walk away and know. So it could be a timing thing like, yeah,
a mother needs to say, you need to sit on your egg for six days. Not Fine,
just don't walk away. But they always walk away.
Actually, no, there are two or three. After 11 years,
there are two to three adult birds in the migratory flock who are hatched in the
wild who were hatched in the wild from captive bred birds.
The rest of them were born here that are in that flock. Now,
does that mean that the countless little babies have died because their mothers
have abandoned them? Yes. Oh, that's tragic. And get this.
Every single one of those birds, once they release them and get them down there,
he's worth about a hundred thousand dollars. Really? Yeah.
In terms of the money that's been put in for training and all that. Yeah.
Oh my God. So not as a collectible, but in terms of investment,
you are a sickness. No, no. Because like, yes, if you're a really rare animal,
like a crane. Yeah. Yeah.
Just being rare makes you valuable in some market around, in this case,
it's sort of like your child is worth, you know, by the time they go to college,
you've spent $900,000 on them. Well, by the time these birds go to college,
they're human parents who spend $100,000 on them. Yeah.
But here's something you're not thinking of. And I haven't said, okay.
And then as these are very long life to birds,
they can live to be 40 and right now we're just seeing the first results of just
the, you know, the success that they've had.
And so now they're just getting to this part really in the story. I see. So,
so the three birds, the three little babies who have hatched out there,
put against the 40 year lifespan means, well,
maybe in a few years they'll get better.
How do we know we're having a real crisis as opposed to a learning curve crisis?
We don't, ah, that's interesting. He thinks,
and you can hear it in his voice.
He thinks they should have gotten better at it by now. Yeah.
I mean there's something more that we need to do to,
to help that population become self sustaining.
There's something else wrong. It feels to me in a very gut sort of way,
that they're not behaving quite right. Yeah.
Not because they haven't learned how,
just a main never learned how may be something broken in them.
It really bothers him too. So given all of this,
hmm.
It's just seem, it's just massively complicated. Why do you,
why are you, why do we do it? Why, why do we humans do? Why are we doing this?
Well, it's the right thing to do.
And Mel, what else are you going to do? I mean, we're not going to give up.
No,
we're gonna find a way to,
to make it work a little bit better and then go have a couple beers.
I mean,
I went into this thinking this is like the coolest thing ever and how noble and
I came out of it really ambivalent actually,
which is totally counter my type.
It is, it is an important undertaking for it itself,
but reestablishing a fully independent flock.
I think maybe a goal that is, that is too,
too hard, but what about a flock that's not fully independent?
I mean if you, if you abandoned the usual idea of conservation,
which is a, you're trying to go back to the way things were before,
we screwed everything up and you just say this is a new species and maybe they
need humans as parents. That's just the way it's going to work. Yeah,
I find that sad.
It's funny because in a sense when they fail reproductively you fail.
Well, I don't know about that reproductively yet. Possibly.
I still have a couple of daughters and they're going to be there.
Whether the crazy they're not, I have, but I gets with these cranes,
whatever happens, we're not going to know for awhile. Yeah.
It's could take a heck of a long time. So, you know, dozens and dozens of years.
[inaudible]
okay, let's get in the car.
[inaudible] a very sincere thanks to Andrea Seabrook for uh,
lending us for amazing talents.
Andrea spent more than a decade covering congress, ran PR,
and she just left to start a new podcast,
which she kickstarted and is now kicking ass.
I would encourage everyone listening to check it out. It's at decode
dc.com decode
dc.com thanks also to Nadiia Wilson for production help and to the folks at the
buttocks and Wildlife Research Center for being so generous with access.
Thank you. I appreciate migration people. Thank you. Cranes. Gacaca.
Hey there,
my name is Greg Fitzpatrick and I'm sitting next to a campfire under a canopy of
stars. Deep in the heart of Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thanks.